[Music]
let's go to hannah in south texas hey
this is a follow-up call what's up
hannah
hi how are you dr john i'm good how are
you
i'm just enjoying the warm weather
it is
that is a very uh optimistic way of
saying what's going on in south texas
right now
it's a little warm-ish yeah
a little warmish
um yeah we're just gonna we're gonna
take a little beach vacation on the sun
right yeah
this morning it was 74 in nashville and
i took a picture and sent sent it to my
friends and there's like uh rain in the
forecast most of the week and i sent it
to my friends in uh in texas i was like
hey what is this what are these clouds
with water falling from them what does
that mean
uh anyway so it's a billion degrees
right now in south texas right
it is yeah we're on the surface of the
sun for sure oh geez i'm sorry but not
sorry so what's up hey so there's a
follow-up call right
it is yeah okay so i'm gonna walk
through the original call
the original call is um you and
your
you were married
i was yeah and then your ex-husband
uh and then you got remarried right you
got divorced and you got remarried
and then your ex-husband
ended up um walking into an apartment or
a home and
taking the life of a couple of people
and then taking his and then taking his
own life down by suicide is that right
yeah so it was his
long-term girlfriend
and her son who was a close friend of
the son that i shared with my ex-husband
all right what a mess miss mess and we
talked just a few days in the aftermath
of that so
um
walk me through it
um
uh so it's been a ride we're still on
the ride um you
had i'd been a long time listener of the
show and was kind of following some of
the advice that you get another so when
i presented
my son with the news
um
i i kind of glossed over it and just
said that his dad had passed away
um and my call to you was how do i
have this conversation of the truth
because it is it was on the news and
um it was very uh publicized and how do
i have this and reconcile
what happened with
this man that you know our son
worshipped as a hero so
um your son's got some um cognitive
exceptionalities right he's yeah
okay
autistic with adhd um
and
he you know i i wanted to wait until the
investigation was closed before
presenting any fax and he would advise
that hey look if this is in the news
this is
it is what it is
um and that i wouldn't be taking
anything away that i had no role in this
and the best thing to do was to be
honest and open with our son
and that's kind of where this journey
started
about a month after
the the incident
we
took your advice and sought out
a counselor who specialized with
neurodivergent children and trauma so we
found that unicorn
that could accommodate a schedule and
we've we and then we started we started
the therapy journey we turned on the
therapy water hose where it was
um
you know
our son was going to therapy then we
were going to family therapy and i was
going to individual therapy because this
resurfaced a lot of trauma from my
marriage
my first marriage and then um
in doing that i had thrown myself into
taking care of my son and dealing with
all of my
trauma and the feelings and
the inconsistent feelings that i was
having because i couldn't understand why
i was sad
to and why i was missing someone that
had you know
it it was a an abusive marriage like how
could i
i couldn't reconcile those feelings so i
was focused
elsewhere so then my current marriage
suffered and
my current husband is a police officer
not a great time to be a police
officer gnarly ride for a few years yeah
and so he
was experiencing some things at work
and
he didn't have a partner
to check in with at home so he was
looking elsewhere and he unfortunately
like many
law enforcement officers do turned to to
drinking heavily and
that presented problems and resurfaced
trauma from being married to an addict
so
he he sought help and therapy on his own
so he now he's seeing therapy and then
we have couples therapy and family
therapy and
we're we're finally getting a foothold
and kind of coming together and
a lot of that um
i lay at your feet because
i will turn on the podcast and it it
never fails but i turn it on and there's
somebody in some form or fashion on the
show that is going through
something that we're currently dealing
with well y'all going through everything
so you're basically everybody's going to
show you we're just going to get it out
we're going to rip the band-aid off
you know we're going to rip the bandaid
off just do it all at once
yeah
hey you mentioned something really
important um is it okay if i ask you a
couple questions
sure um first how did the conversation
go with your
son
and i asked that is um
i'm always interested if somebody calls
back and says hey we took your advice it
was terrible we should not have done
what you said um
and also
most people could never imagine
having to sit down with their child and
say
your dad
did something horrific and your dad was
sick and your dad is no longer with like
the th that is so out of the realm of
somebody's
somebody's
a normal just a regular run-of-the-mill
person walking down the street
walk us through that
um
so the conversation i really didn't have
a choice but to have the conversation
because he found an article okay um and
the article kind of glossed over it and
just said that there there were guns
found at the scene
um
and so
this was after my call with you and
again got down i sat on the floor he sat
on the couch
and i i had to put it in context so we
watch a lot of the the law and order
type shows and i said you know how
when we're watching the show they can't
just jump to a conclusion they have to
put the pieces together
so
at the time i had given you the
information that i had which was you
know your dad and the others
they had died
um i didn't have details and the
detectives didn't have details but the
detectives had to do their job and put
the pieces together
and what those pieces determined was
that
this happened now just because this
happened
um
oh and i i checked in with him i said do
you have any questions about that and he
said no
and all right so two things for the
person listening
real important when you have hard
conversations with kids even in their
early teens
getting below their level or getting eye
contact level with them is really
important when you have a hard
conversation from a power position one
down it can be unnerving for a child
puts them in a state of fight or flight
and then you have this hard news so
brilliant number one number two
genius
connecting a hard conversation to
something that your son can anchor into
yeah it's it's uh
my my i took my four-year-old when our
dog died and we buried that dog on my
friend's ranch but we dug the hole
together that moment has allowed us to
talk about death when grandparents and
went out could we have an anchor point
and you brilliant job great job you did
there awesome thank you so good
um
thank you
so he he said he didn't have any
questions
and i said okay what i need you to
understand and what i need you to
remember and i will be here to remind
you for all of your days
is that this in no way shape or form
has anything to do with you has anything
to do with how your dad loved you with
how proud he was of you it is not a
reflection on you
i was like your dad was sick
and i just left it at that
you are unbelievable
you're an amazing mom
thank you
like
for real that's really really powerful
yeah um
it's very hard yeah
and we didn't
um
you know we didn't start
therapy right away i said you know i'm
i'm looking for someone for you to talk
to
is that okay
and he said oh i think i'm good mom and
i was like okay
we'll watch this
um and i was interviewing several
therapists and if i didn't like the vibe
i i wasn't even going to to waste our
time
um and then something
he was in spanish class and they had a
day of the dead project and they had to
make the little ofrenda where they had
to make the memorial and um
he really the only person that he knows
that's died was his dad so he made that
that resurfaced a bunch of questions
um and so where i'm answering the
questions and i've always said even when
his dad was alive i'll answer any
question you want
um you know and
we were digging through photos and he
found a photo of
his his dad's biological father and he
said who's that and i was like that's
that's your grandfather that's your
dad's dad
well that doesn't look like papa and i
was like okay
okay this is your dad's dad
unfortunately he died when your dad was
younger
well how did he die
well
um
he committed suicide oh wow
so then you have this beautiful autistic
brain sitting there
who looks for patterns in the world
that's right he said well if my dad did
it
and his dad did it does that mean i'm
going to do it
and never
never ever ever ever ever
did i think that i would
have to to answer or visit that question
yeah
um
and i the only thing i could say is i
certainly hope not because
and the difference is is you have a
support system and you have a mom who is
here for you and loves you and i will
move heaven and earth to get you
whatever help that you need
do you want to talk to somebody
mom i want to talk to somebody
got it and you know i had a list of
people that i thought were would be a
good fit and that's when we
started the weekly sessions with our
unicorn who's been great for the almost
year now so
it's been arrived it's been
yeah
yeah
this is not and what to what what to
expect when you're expecting no they
they left them i think this chapter got
cut out yeah they left this one
completely out
um yeah i i
can i change one thing for you to tell
this young boy moving forward
sure if he ever asked that question
again
smile and say no
not i hope not not i think not
smile and say no
because now he
has a um
he's got a path laid out in front of him
that he knows the ending of
and now that we know that if you drive
down that road here's what's at the end
of that road we're not going to take
that road and if we find ourselves on
that road we can hit the brakes
right and
so we now have a path elsewhere
and this other path is going to be hard
because we don't know it it's going to
be new it's going to be us in the woods
that's what counseling is it's teaching
us how to make new paths in the woods
and someone's going to walk with us
that's what a counselor does um that's
what your unicorn does with you
um but the answer is just a smile on it
no
you're stuck with me for the long haul
yeah and when the light feels really low
we're gonna remember granddad and we're
gonna remember dad and we're gonna make
that phone call
and so in a strange way
a very strange way it's a surreal
experience you're having and i know that
um we're norming
death by suicide because it's happened
twice in the lineage
it is our life
right yeah
um it's our life and so since it's our
life same with um grandad was um
struggling with i don't know
uh
any number of things
granddad had cancer dad had cancer i now
know i'm going to be extra careful about
my tests and about my diet and about
fill in the blank right
um
granddad was uh 300 pounds overweight
and struggled with disorder eating his
whole life dad was struggling with
disordering i know i'm gonna have to be
on top of that stuff and so it gives us
a path right it's not deterministic but
it gives us a path so
anyway that
i i'm just telling you um you i mean you
listen to the show
i think uh you need to start your own
podcast on how to be a good mom i mean
it's just amazing it's amazing okay i
want to touch on one other thing before
i let you go is that cool sure um
because this comes up a lot a lot a lot
a lot
um
and that is
loving somebody
being in relationship with someone being
married to somebody being a partnership
with somebody
while they're experiencing trauma
and
the
this is a terrible analogy and so
forgive me and for everybody on the
internets who are mean just don't be
mean about this that's just a not a good
analogy but
um it's a time when i was a kid i was
riding a little scooter and i
slipped out in the street and my feet
got caught behind me and they were
dragging until i stopped and so i pulled
all the skin and down to the muscle off
of my feet and i ran inside and my
parents were gone and just my sister was
there and she was a kid too so i'm not
mad at all
but her first words were ah you're
getting blood on the carpet
not oh my gosh you look really hurt
and so there's something about being
connected to somebody who's struggling
and you've got a wound and you're
getting blood on the sheets you're
getting blood on the carpet
and yet i'm still trying to care i'm
trying to care about you because you're
clearly hurt
and there's a tension there when i know
my wife is
getting the care she needs she's getting
the counseling she needs she's been
through hell and back and why does she
keep talking about this x
why is she feeling so down what about me
why doesn't she f right and so that
question what about me
comes up and it's not a people like to
make it a character thing it's not it's
a human nature thing do you still love
me do you still see me do i still belong
and at the same time you're going
through hell
right
walk us through that in your marriage
oh um
so like i mentioned he was an officer
and he had experienced
outside of just day-to-day trauma that
officers experience um true trauma
where um
you know a gentleman passed away in
custody
um
and
you know it
it led to
he's he's a very stoic
um
i i don't want to put my burdens on you
and it's been like that since
the dating ages so
um
very stoic don't want to burden you with
my my problems i'm here to support you
and relieve you of everything you
carried in your first marriage is how
this has been and i
i just kind of left it at that and so i
i wasn't checking in because i got tired
of checking in and being like it's fine
i i don't you don't need to worry about
it like i've got it that that that
stoicism um
left me not having a place to help him
um and let me say let me say a different
way that stoicism is a brick wall it's a
concrete pillar
it's hollow
and it's less about you being able to
help him but there's no way for you to
plug in
right
that's exactly what it was so i and
that's that's what it had come down to
is i had checked out that is i was like
okay well if you don't need me i need to
help myself and i know my son needs me
so this is where i'm putting my
resources like um
and he
you know i threw myself into
fair you know individual therapy and
therapy for
my son and
and work got crazy so i was trying to
deal with craziness at work and you know
let's throw in building a house in this
crazy market why not why not uh and it's
a billion degrees
a billion degrees surface of the sun so
the only thing that he had to do
not the only thing the the path that he
chose to take was drinking so a few
beers after shift turned into
a six-pack turned into a a night cap
turned into
half a bottle turned into a bottle
and
so it it kind of we we hit um we hit the
wall
um
around the holidays because there's
never stress at the holidays
um
and uh we hit the wall and quite
literally holes in the wall
and i left
um and i said i'm not doing this again i
did it in my first marriage we don't
need this you figure your stuff out any
good
so
can i say this
i have a friend who
his dog got hit by car
his beloved dog and he ran out in the
street to grab this dog and it reached
up and it bit him
it was hurt so bad
it just snapped
right and he ended up having to go to
the hospital and get stitches in his
hand and he was also heartbroken the dog
ended up passing away it was a mess
but i remember
him saying i can't be mad at the dogs i
was hurt right and the dog mistook me
for a threat and i tell you to say this
sometimes when we are recovering from
major trauma and from hurt and from pain
things just end up like you said all
over the place up against the wall like
all over the place and there's this
moment of the lights are on
i'm sorry and i still love you and i'm
sorry i still love you let's figure this
out and it sounds like that's been
y'all's adventure moving forward
yes so
um
i i had offered
help up until up until that point and
again it's i couldn't plug in like we we
could we were so disconnected
um to it um
that i was like if you're not going to
talk to me
you need to figure this out
um
and
and he did it was i mean the next day
phone calls were made
so he sought intensive treatment and
therapy
and and you know
we've been back together and it's been
we are making it work whether it be you
know telehealth appointments through
better help where you know he finds a
parking lot and i'm in the parking lot
at lunch and
we're we're having these couple weekly
couples sessions we're making that a
priority and still
working on ourselves and still working
to fix this for our son
um and navigate what this looks like
because now we have to be the bridge to
the other side you know whereas before
it was his dad that was maintaining
those relationships
you know the only way to access this is
for
us to to reach out to
his dad's family and say hey
what do you what do you want to do i'd
like for you all to continue to be part
of his life
so we have this weird very modern
family-ish
thing
going on that neither of us ever thought
we would have coming from divorced homes
ourselves
where
once a month we're up with my
ex-sister-in-laws you know
in north texas spending time so he can
connect with his cousins and all that
other stuff i it's it's a wild wild ride
and i just
thank you for starting us on it i think
i i just
i mean you can say thank you to me i'm
just in here in awe i'm i think i'm i
i'm thinking you
um for your bravery and for your
continued
getting back up and going again
and the
the words that keep coming to mind as
i'm listening to you is you did it
anyway
you didn't want to have that hard
conversation he did anyway
and you didn't want to deal with the
trauma that you had just tried to marry
into and to do away with you married a
a different version
right
and of the same issue and
uh
then you decided to deal with the trauma
and you did it anyway and then your
marriage got really hard it got scary
and you just had to do it anyway and now
you're having to figure out a new life
that was not in your plans at all
and you're doing it anyway and i i've
come to believe that the phrase do it
anyway is the cornerstone of physical
and mental health like yes do it take
your meds do whatever you gotta do do it
anyway and
so thank you
thank you hannah
it's amazing
and the last thing i'll tell you is
moving through this new season
is gonna take
super tight committed boundaries with
you and your husband who that guy sounds
like a rock star too i mean just an
amazing man um to be able to run up
against his limitations and say
i can no longer
like try to bang my head against this
concrete wall i hope it'll fall down i
gotta take a knee here i gotta call
somebody what a that's a modern-day hero
man everybody involved here
um
really incredible
really really really incredible
huh
very gross yeah it's just amazing